Hi. In this video, we'll look at working with JWTs in Burp Suite.
JSON Web Tokens are a standard format for sending cryptographically signed JSON data between systems.
They're commonly used in authentication, session management, and access control mechanisms.
This means that if an attacker can successfully modify a JWT, they may be able to escalate their own privileges or impersonate other users.
You can use Burp Inspector to view and decode JWTs.
You can then use the JWT Editor extension to generate cryptographic signing keys, edit the JWT,
and re-sign the token with a valid signature that corresponds to the edited JWT.
If you'd like to follow along, you can use our JWT authentication bypass via unverified signature lab in our Web Security Academy.
Before we start, we'll need to make sure that we've installed the JWT Editor extension from Burp's BAP store.
I've already installed it here and have generated some traffic on the target application by logging in, so we're ready to go.
If we go to Burp's Proxy HTTP History tab, we can look for requests with a JWT to investigate further.
As we've got the JWT Editor extension installed, these are automatically highlighted and flagged for us.
To view the JWT contents, highlight sections of the token in turn.
Notice that the content is automatically decoded in the Inspector panel.
Now you can review the contents of the JWT in the Inspector panel to identify interesting information and determine any modifications that you want to make.
To edit a JWT, we can use the JWT Editor extension.
Right-click the request you want to edit, select Send to Repeater and go to the Repeater tab.
In the Request panel, go to the JSON Web Token tab.
Edit to the JSON data as required in the Header and Payload fields.
Click Sign and a new dialog will open.
In the dialog, select the appropriate signing key and then click OK.
The JWT will be re-signed to correspond with the new values in the Header and Payload.
If you haven't added a signing key, you can go to the JWT Editor Keys tab.
Click the button for the type of key you want to add, for example, New Symmetric Key,
and a new dialog will open where you can add the new key by clicking on Generate to create a new key,
or alternatively by pasting in an existing key into the dialog.
Edit the key as needed and click OK to save it.